this week we've got electric chopsticks
Oh wrong hole
Oh sounds nice and cool manicure cool
part three of cruel intentions I did the
wrong on accident once we talk about
that when we get to this electric
chopsticks is the first one yep so what
is the electric chopstick that's gonna
work great for you yeah I might need
this
mm-hmm you can't use chopsticks she
treats it like a pencil like she's hella
low on it yo you're supposed to right
hold it like a pencil yeah that's like
how there no but she's like at the
bottom like what mm-hmm that's how kids
do it but as you get older you go on
higher higher higher so you do
chopsticks like this yeah she's writing
an essay writing my name where you going
they're all strong I think you're about
to get chopstick handling one oh why oh
please please help there you go that's
that bad I just started going so this is
how you think can I tell you something
real quick your left hand is nice why's
that doesn't make sense there's no
strength here right right gots to back
it up girl right dear
so now I can get more fit more strength
point of chopsticks and so your foods
your hands not in the food by germs
before you you are lying
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay boyfriend it's really good you got
it creative and she's like baby I'm okay
I'm okay
no I got you I got you all right so the
electric chopsticks that we're talking
about here are these chopsticks that are
being developed they're pretty much
zapping your taste buds so you can taste
things at our saltier when they're bland
or sweeter when they're not sweeter oh
cool Dean your mind so you can eat
healthier sorry
well you could just eat healthy right
yeah but a lot of people don't like the
taste of bland food mmm
wait so this is it of course yapping or
tongue will attack its ending like tiny
little electric shocks to trick your
tongue your taste buds into tasting a
certain tip oh they'll be so dope I
think you could program like the [ __ ]
electric shocks to make it taste like
something like beef stew mmm it's just
water
like salty sweet okay the popcorn butter
popcorn popcorn butter popcorn spicy
yeah yeah yeah that's it that's exactly
what it say they can make kimchi not
taste like kimchi I'll probably eat it
you like
roomful Asian stuff I mean I love not it
tastes it tastes well maybe i'm judging
a book by it's cover but smells weird
you've never even tasted it no try on
titan right you punk [ __ ]
come on Hamburger Helper like coupon
soften up bro what happens I just
finally had sushi you really well I mean
the shrimp tempura yeah I've had a like
once hmm you don't like it either no I
liked it really yeah way to go be with
kimchi mmm that's delicious but you
never had kimchi so you wouldn't know
yeah but I'm just trying to like smell
the fish and go there Kim is there fish
in kimchi it's official oh no do you
like fish
not a stick there's no well there's no
fish in that then it's fish sauce yeah I
don't even smell fish and kimchi whoa
boy
if you grew up with it you don't say
smells vinegar yeah was in kimchi is
there a green cabbage it depends so it's
napa cabbage typically oh that's why
there's healthy stuff you know paprika
paprika as they call it paprika how did
you say now the cabbage yeah napa
cabbage like from Napa Valley yeah napa
cabbage they call that cabbage
okay fish sauce green onions salt sugar
that's what is ferment and all the
liquid comes from a Korean grandma
supplies spitting Kenny was spinning it
just like a loaf will saliva it's how
it's ferments in its own juices
so it's with the salt and everything
else and then they just stays in there
ferments Oh
but yeah so you know how a lot of people
tend to take a lot of soda
is really bad for your health that's why
they're developing these chopsticks so
people don't have so much sodium or
sugar or a lot of spicy stuff that even
bad in Singapore I like America would
need that before Singapore you know
there are developing in the University
of Singapore but then this doctor that's
working on it then went over to
University of Maine
so I guess sad if I can't have flavors I
know that's why this if you're trying to
be healthy absolutes pretty good
I would definitely meet we could have
flavors but still not get that all right
yeah we shot sure many spots but is only
giving you the sense of delivers pulses
of electricity to the tip of the tongue
it's like a mouth greater dim you know
it's like a dog collar for Asians I know
but it's not good to make like broccoli
tastes like pizza though you know it was
just making a little more salts not bad
for you either it is too much sodium
yeah but you could always drink water or
sweat it off that's true too
to the mall to the regular person though
that's not completely informed they just
see high sodium as a bad thing so this
could help them off that's true but
nothing replaces a pizza or spam yeah or
a burgers but damn chopsticks are going
when people tell me to eat nothing but
Blanchette I feel like they're talking
[ __ ] to me so bad at your doctor is like
hey maybe you should eat a little
healthier you call me a [ __ ]
yeah I'm just lying trusting my lies you
say like man you've got a mind your own
business
seriously you trying to take my life doc
yeah the mother to kill you like Jo
would you like some quinoa he said at
the doctor's appointment of the body's
old business I know it's like a watch
well you I don't get you everything
doctors actually listened to themselves
because my doctor was a look like he had
too much sodium he told me are you like
you know like when people like write
quotes on Instagram they're really
telling themselves yeah oh yeah I felt
like my doctor was doing that like the
hashtag I think he was telling me like
maybe we should slow down your sodium
and I'm like you didn't take anything
from me is you wouldn't know
you were telling yourself you want to
race [ __ ] all right right next
story there's this couple that they were
trying to conceive for the past four
years they were trying really really but
they kept putting it in the butthole but
they kept putting it in the butt really
much they didn't know and it's - do you
know which one like who was putting in
whose ball that would have been even
though after four years of trying to
conceive they went to the doctor and
it's a guy in a girl right it's a guy in
a girl okay the doctor thought that
maybe the the woman she probably had
some sort of like something going on
down there that's not right that's
preventing her from getting pregnant so
when she went to examine her she
realized that the woman was still a
virgin
but she could fit three fingers in her
butthole easily can you be like a whole
fish damn wife is 24 both in good health
so this is what happens she went to go
get like a little Pappy right and then
she opened up the thing and then she
they were putting into her vagina like
no no you got to go lower it's like no
man no here hey dumbass doctor vaginas
south yeah it's where the brown crust is
this would have happened if they had my
mom as their mom because my mom told me
that babies come out of the bajo so they
probably grew up thinking that there's
no such thing as a vagina I just saw the
weirdest [ __ ] toy being advertised on
TV so it's made by Mattel or something
it's this golden retriever you press the
golden retriever down and then puppies
come out of its stomach Oh puppies oh
that's weird
for two reasons why because it's false
it's a c-section
yeah it doesn't come out of there comes
out of the freaking vagina hole and then
the other one is why does it kidney to
know like me to play with the pregnant
dog and there's like this red gums that
comes on it and [ __ ] all these kids are
slimy all the BLA be cool if it came out
like for real like in little slime bags
and [ __ ] I'd be cool do man watching a
dog birth is disgusting it's really
girly this comes out and the dogs just
eating the [ __ ] [ __ ] first period
oh it is
morning covered in blood and slime it
eats the placenta - what if they did get
pregnant and then they found out it's
been nothing so it was a case like that
where there's no way what the anus and
the vagina was connected remember what
okay yeah so she was that's a dirty
[ __ ] cuz what if the poop will leak
through why the internal dirty [ __ ] hmm
that's a that's a does the man that goes
from anal back to vagina back and forth
pow pow pow I only like that impor not a
real life man it's not the same so you
know it's not the same I try to smell
like it all infections is crazy he told
us about the boot the [ __ ] [ __ ]
nuggets thank you mother
Dookie no get that came out oh wait I
did it but she asked me to that's funny
you did a pun there she is
[Music]
yes so anyway so then the doctor
informed this couple hey it's not that
hole it's this other hole and like
that's what is a [ __ ] I understand now
it's so much better we're girls yeah I'm
like a sex ed brochure and they sent
them on their way and a few months later
they found out that she was pregnant
oh they sent over the doctor a live
chicken and a hundred eggs as a token of
their thing what kinda country place
that's as countries like China oh my god
this poor girl had her freaking go
through anal oh she was saying that sex
is always exceptionally painful for her
but she was just going through a baby I
bet you for [ __ ] dowry she got traded
for a goat or something - how did the
doctor figure out that she could stick
three fingers in there don't it fell
because one two maybe four no - and I
think what's funnier is that the author
of this our
like we have to include that yeah
because that's how much she tried like
that's how [ __ ] spread her ass I
can't even put a pinkie in that [ __ ] so
painful and then it's gonna shoot out of
her mouth how did two people not know it
that's where I'm confused like you
uneducated they're both versions maybe
parents never talked to them about sex
yeah they never seen porn they never is
it like are they are they each other's
first or has she been doing this for a
while and every day oh no the whole male
village be doing it in the butt
because it might be actually all the
dudes might just think that the booty
100% sure the whole village is playing a
prank on them right there right there
all the time you know what this one what
you want you're pregnant right you want
to get pregnant yeah this is the right
one come on mom four years
look at these dumb [ __ ] all right last
story so there's an Elvis a lot of poo
poo dick this nail salon and Russia is
being slammed for animal cruelty because
they used live ends in a manicure what
who cares is handsome I saw this that's
me when I said my horrible person I'm
like animal cruelty for real dude I used
to just roast those [ __ ]
that's mean wait wait wait mash them all
the time where they're around oh my god
what's the wait a minute
is there a reason why you know this is
what they look like but I'll show you a
video and whoa wait
are they dead or alive they're alive so
they move in the night so this is how
they created these nails oh that thing's
freaking that [ __ ] what is this before
after
I'll show you in this video but they
have they created these nails or they're
hollowed out so they do the whole nails
and then they stick the ant inside and
then they seal it a little bit and then
they show it's being reported that they
did show the ants being released so they
weren't there for long oh just for like
this quick video wait so they eat away
what's inside the nail they're not
eating anything
no they just hang out and it's like a
little fish tank I'll I can always just
for fun yeah
ant farm nails oh they were released him
after why would this like ant cruelty is
out there saying animal cruelty that
what they're saying yeah another do they
smell like a NT I am at tomorrow and
tomorrow looks weird though yeah for
sure so it's okay to kill him why you
can't put him in her nails and then give
him back their life you know what
I was always out when I saw that I was
thinking like how long do they survive
for in the fingernail well how long they
survive in general there's no might be
promo for like the next ants film it's
considered conspiracy oh wow how long he
lived the black garden ants is 15 years
why because in my house they live about
three seconds I blast those mother
[ __ ] dude when you blast them with
the [ __ ] ant spray the raid dude they
die so fast
some of them go through life never ever
[ __ ] him
yeah a lot a sexual love amazing we can
live up to 30 years feed the Queens they
do all the producing wait so the Queen
has a bunch of them I think they're like
beans yeah like some of them are ours
oh they're saying workers live from
about one to three years but so we never
warm do you kind know you are yeah
really yeah you already like this aunt
or your that Android whatever they got
language yeah they're smart or he's like
body language from the B movie I just
know these yeah it's not a quality I'll
tell you that oh yeah so a lot of people
are saying that they're trying to
boycott this now
salon where's it at a horrible Russia in
Moscow or is that like a huge auntie of
like we love it yeah I don't know I'm
trying to figure that out too like I
think I understand I guess is kind of
unusual but then there's there are ant
farms where they actually had them in a
glass thing anyways but they don't
release them so yeah these ones are
released at least it's kind of
refreshing to know that there's there's
actually people fighting for insects cuz
I always thought that daling like the
furry ones and they don't like the nasty
insects I'm like okay cool there's
actually people that care about insects
too whenever I see an AI trying to crush
it immediately me too and there's
probably some type of evolutionary like
thing that makes humans just hate
insects especially when they got a
little less milk my legs or like some
[ __ ] I feel like it's kind of nice
that like we either just kill them right
away cuz we used to just eat them right
evolution says that has food we just eat
well I saw it in that one wasn't it
anteaters alpha a little wolf movie oh
yeah they eat ate bugs yeah it was based
on the like back in the day yeah and I
was like that's worse
yeah you love crickets yeah you haven't
read oh I ate a crab before it's a lie
she knows a cricket tastes grassy all
you knew the cricket very salty berries
have you had one yeah we all have one
drive it would get some and then he
would put like lime on it and they're
like oh like we marinated the shitty it
was pretty good it's like I just didn't
like the head no the head was all spiky
it was the what is it like the lake
that's the part that was too crunchy
that was like did you feel like when you
bite into it there's like juice that
comes out yeah that's the part another
game speed well I had it with lime so it
made a bit it's like eating a shrimp you
actually know that made it worse
deep-fry it did I'm gonna need a
tarantula really bad oh we got some we
got some in the prop room all this wrong
office okay no point oh we got some over
there really I hate my flies like in
Cambodia and Thailand we had these huge
like underground tarantulas yeah my
Andrew Zimmern like usually the crew
doesn't like the food by the way
eet's they said that that tarantula
tastes just like a crap so eat a crab
dude oh crap yeah do they eat the butt
cheek part cuz that part looks weird I
just imagine biting into it all kinds of
guns come out like the leg part they
just either all furry there's a nice
fatty they deep-fry it so it just hey
you want to eat that they defang it and
they put it in like Jane you can't eat
can't you you know I do is they said it
tastes just like a soft-shell crab but
better better abdomen that's where they
wait how big how big are these big like
crap wait am i show me your hands Oh
spider they're huge and they did they
dig they dig them in the goo yeah but
that's crab not a spider it's the same
thing pretty much they don't stick to
the crab crab is like sea spiders crabs
are a pretty [ __ ] ugly - yeah [ __ ]
hideous I don't think about it I tease
tarantulas you might even think about
that
I'm gonna boil some pretty soon what I'm
gonna boil some crabs
[Music]